بعد تراجع اليات الاحتلال من هنا من جبالي
البلد تمكنا من الوصول لهذه المنطقه لرصد
حجم هذا الدمار وحجم هذه الجريمه هنا في
جبالي البلد كانت تتمركز قوات الاحتلال
واليات الاحتلال في هذه المنطقه في جباليا
البلد قامت بتدمير جميع المنازل هذا جزء
مما نستطيع رصده وتوثيقه من الدمار في هذه
المنطقه طبعا اليات الاحتلال زالت تتواجد
على اطراف جباليا البلد وكل من يحاول
الوصول لهذه المناطق تقوم اليات الاحتلال
باطلاق قذائف المدفعيه على المواطنين
واطلاق النار ايضا من قبل طائرات كواد
كابتر في هذه المناطق دمار لا بيت ولا شجر
ولا حجر يعني شي لا يوصف همجيه لا توصف
بشكل بشكل
مخيف
نحن الان نتواجد هنا في منطقه العلاوين
هنا في جباليا البلد هذه المنطقه التي
تعرضت للقصف
العنيف وهناك كان عدد من الشهداء في هذه
المنطقه عدد كبير الاحتلال ارتكب
مجازر هنا في في منطقه اللاوين في جبالي
البلد طبعا الاحتلال جرف عشرات المنازل
هنا وتمركزت اليه الاحتلال في هذا الشارع
اثناء توغل الاحتلال في جباليا احنا ما
كنا نتصور انه الارهاب الصهيوني بالصوره
هذه انه يحر يقلب الارض كلها يقلب الدور
على في ناس ابرياء كانت تحت البيوت تحت
الدور مركباتنا البصات شر بصات شح كله كل
الدنيا انحرقت احنا رجعنا من مدارسنا ما
عرفنا البلد اللي احنا فيها ما عرفناها
انا صرت اتوه عن الشارع اللي بعد على بلدي
على الشارع على داري الدار اللي انا فيها
انا تهت تهت بالحرف الواحد اني اعد على
بيتي صار عندي مسح مسح قلب في دور ماي
مبينه ارض حمراء ارض حمراء وزي ما انتم
شايفين هنا اطلعوا كيف هنا هذه كلها في
مناطق يشهد الله يا جماعه في العالم كله
احنا الاراضي هنا اختفت د كامله كانت
موجوده اختفت عن الوجود وين راحت ما بنعرف
اثر بلوك اثر دعم اثر عمدان ما في اي
حاجه كما نشاهد ونحن في المكان طائرات
الاحتلال تقوم بالقاء عدد من القنابل
الدخانيه هنا على جباليا
البلد الان نقترب من مفترق الحلبي هنا في
جباليا البلد هنا كانت اليات الاحتلال
تتمركز في هذا
المكان
[موسيقى]
قوات الاحتلال تقوم
باطلاق النار على هذه المناطق الان احنا
يعني تعبانين تعبانين جدا الناس وهي اطلاق
النار والدبابات وعدوا جباليا مرتين ثلاثه
وللان موجودين في اسرائيل في جباليا تصاعد
الدخان هنا في جباليا البلد نتيجه القصف
المستمر الذي لم يتوقف حتى هذه
اللحظه هذه الصور هذا مركز جباليا الطبي
الذي دمره الاحتلال بالكامل وهذا المركز
الوحيد الذي كان يعمل هنا في شمال القطاع
ويستقبل
الاصابات بعد تراجع اليات الاحتلال وقواته
من هذه المناطق دمار كبير وعشرات الشهداء
ما زالوا تحت الركام انس الشريف الجزيره
شمال غزه